Robert Spencer here for Jihadwatch, a
program of the David Harowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy, with more of the truth about the
Hamas linked Council on American Islamic
Relations, the unsavory organization,
popularly known as CARE. CARE has now
launched what World Bulletin
characterized as a satirical public
awareness campaign to challenge growing
Islamophobia in America.
K explains in a press release saying
prompted at least in part by anti-Muslim
rhetoric employed by public figures like
Donald Trump and other GOP candidates,
we decided to launch Islamophobin. With
Islamophobin, we hope to dispel a
serious problem with a witty and
humorous manner. Buy and distribute
Islamophobin to help us dispel
Islamophobia. Islamophobin is really a
pack of gum. care is congratulating
itself on its witty and humorous idea,
but it isn't even original to the group.
Back in 2010, I was speaking in Sweden,
and I was handed during one talk a box
of Islamophobial pills that promised to
cure Islamophobia and promote
multiculturalism and open-mindedness. I
wonder if Care is paying a royalty to
the people who marketed those
Islamophobia pills. But anyway, Car's
self-proclaimed witty and humorous new
product claims to cure blind
intolerance, unthinking bigotry,
irrational fear of Muslims, and US
presidential election year scapegoating.
It even promises that it spreads love.
Now, in the first place, aren't there
laws against making false claims for a
product? But let's take them at their
word. Islamophobin gum cures blind
intolerance. Well, that's great. That's
really wonderful. So if Sed Rizswan
Farooq and Tashi Malik had been chewing
away on some Islamophob, they wouldn't
have stormed a Christmas party in San
Bernardino in December 2015, and
murdered 14 non-Muslims, right? If
Islamic jihadists had had some
Islamophobin gum the previous month,
November 2015, they wouldn't have
murdered 130 people in Paris, right? And
apparently if they had had some of this
miracle love spreading gum in Brussels
in March 2016, they wouldn't have
murdered 32 people and wounded over 300
in bombings at the airport and the metro
station. This wonderful gum also cures
unthinking bigotry. So if it could be
distributed widely in Pakistan,
presumably it would prevent Christians
from being victimized by bogus blasphemy
charges for crimes such as trying to
prevent Christian girls from mus from
being attacked by Muslim bullies. If it
had been available in Egypt, it would
presumably keep Muslim mobs from
stripping old Christian women naked and
parading them through villages as a
Muslim mob did in the Egyptian village
of Minya in in the spring of 2016. But
of course, I'm getting carried away.
This new wonder drug won't do any of
those things. After all, it's called
Islamophobin, not Christianophobin or
jihadophobin. It's meant to combat
irrational fear of Muslims, not
irrational persecution of Christians or
jihad mass murder. Hamas linked care has
always been far more concerned about
stamping out what it calls Islamophobia.
that is any investigation into how
Islamic jihadists use Islamic texts and
teachings to justify violence and
supremacism than they've ever been
concerned about combating jihad terror
which has never been on their priority
list at all. In the Hamas linked care
video about
Islamophob, there is a non-Muslim who
has an irrational fear of Muslims
because he envisions his neighbor as a
sword wielding jihadi screaming Aakbar
while striking out at the shrubbery with
a sword. A cynical trivialization of the
numerous beheadings and other murders
we've seen committed by Muslims who were
screaming Allah Akbar and wielding
swords quite lethally. Anyway, after he
takes an Islamophobin, the Islamophobe
is able to see his Muslim neighbor for
what he is, an ordinary, harmless, even
cuddly guy. The point is that if you
have a Muslim neighbor and you regard
him with suspicion, you're an
irrational, intolerant bigot. Now what
were the neighbors of Saiad Rswan Farooq
and Tashi Malik and Jakim Israel and
Ibrahim Simpson and Muhammad Abdulaziz
and Tamarind Sarnayv and Nidal Malik
Hassan and all the many other jihadis
and jihad plotters caught in the United
States. What would the neighbors of
those people think about that? If Hamas
linked Care honestly wanted to combat
irrational fear of Muslims, it would
confront seriously and publicly the real
reasons why people have any fear of
Muslims at all. Not because of
intolerance and bigotry, but because of
jihad terror attacks perpetrated by
Muslims who justify their actions by
referring to the Quran and Sunnah. This
Islamophob gum is just another salvo in
K's yearslong project of conflating
legitimate concern about an opposition
to jihad terror and Islamic supremacism
with hatred and bigotry. There is no
opposition to terrorism that speaks
honestly about its motives and goals
that care has ever found acceptable.
Anyone and everyone who dares to note
how Islamic teachings are justifi are
used by Islamic jihadis to justify
violence and hatred and make recruits
among peaceful Muslims is vilified as a
bigot. The obvious goal is to discredit
and marginalize every foe of jihad
terror so that no one dares speak out
against it and it can advance unimpeded
and
unopposed. But as the West inches ever
closer to subjugation and slavery, at
least infidels will have something to
chew on. I'm Robert Spencer.